but first all eyes of the world on great
britain queen elizabeth ii has died at
96 years old she ruled for so long most
people of britain have never known
another monarch here's ian lee looking
back at her life
even into her 90s queen elizabeth ii
kept up her royal duties she became the
longest reigning monarch in british
history in 2015. inevitably a long life
can pass by many milestones
my own is no exception
elizabeth alexandra mary windsor was not
in line to be queen but in 1936 the
ten-year-old princess nicknamed lillibet
was put on the fast track after her
uncle king edward viii abdicated to
marry an american divorcee
elizabeth's father became king george vi
then elizabeth became first in line as
her country fought world war ii the
young royal was thrust into another
spotlight
[Music]
she made her first radio broadcast to
our country in 1940 a message of
encouragement to children forced to
leave their homes to escape the dangers
of war and when peace comes
remember
it will be for us the children of today
to make the world of tomorrow a better
and happier place after world war ii in
1947 elizabeth gave england something to
celebrate she married philip mountbatten
a member of the greek royal family the
following year the first of their four
children was born charles the next
prince of wales
her father king george died in 1952.
at 25 years old elizabeth became queen
millions watched the first ever
televised crowning of a british monarch
queen elizabeth worked with more than a
dozen british prime ministers beginning
with winston churchill and was head of
state in 15 other commonwealth countries
a series of royal dramas marked her
reign her son andrew's high-profile
marriage to sarah ferguson failed and in
1992 her oldest son charles separated
from princess diana
that same year the queen watched part of
windsor castle go up in flames
destroying millions in art and furniture
1992
is not a year on which i shall look back
with undiluted pleasure in 1997 a car
crash in paris killed princess diana
stunning the world many criticized the
queen for not showing emotion
more than a decade later the queen
celebrated a royal wedding as her
grandson prince william married kate
middleton the couple gave the queen
three heirs to the throne
her majesty marked 60 years on the
throne in 2012 when a thousand ships
sailed the river thames to honor her and
in 2016 queen elizabeth celebrated her
90th birthday thousands packed the
streets of windsor to catch a glimpse of
the only monarch most had ever known
the queen watched another tiny royal
join the family after her youngest
grandson prince harry married meghan
markle
just a few years later the queen lost
her husband of 73 years she called the
death of prince philip a huge void in
her life but she carried on
and at 96 years old celebrated her
platinum jubilee the week of fanfare and
festivities marked the queen's 70 years
on the british throne
ian lee cbs news london
truly just a remarkable life along with
her grandchildren and great
grandchildren the queen had a lifelong
love of corgi dogs in fact she owned
more than 30 during her reign